established
so I just want to share with you um the
the rational of why we built this and
this is actually a Five Years Journey
um in our in our business units
so um just as a reminder our Chris
review and
um that's the thumb here at 10 A.M
um can you usually get everything else
because it's probably going to be hard
to find about it but
um but the rationale about building uh
how would you give me handheld actually
started thinking uh a gaming devices for
ourselves so back in the 90s you know
when when gaming was was a cultural
filament and it started to be
cross-loaded not just limited arcades or
um all your living rooms um gaming
handheld like Game Boy was always in the
gaming theme along with the whole living
room console as well as PC gaming but
the the revolution of um give me
Hangouts actually way slower
way slower than the living room console
game board
uh the PC game in a while it evolved
into cinematic Graphics in the early
2000s you know gave me a handheld was
still on the 3D games you know I mean
your Game Boy was like the Mega Man's or
the street fighter in 3D
um and when it evolves into 720p and
1080p where you can really take the the
Polish of the graphics and the
computational graphics it actually fell
behind even today gaming handheld is
predominantly a 720p type of experience
and for gamers like us we really want to
make a device that is you know not
compromised for you know play the best
games at home and then when you're out
on the road just play whatever you can
what if we want advice for ourselves
that this 1080p gaming we can enjoy the
graphics on the road and that's why the
whole restaurant of the Immunology
um first of all this is not a product
that we can build by ourselves today we
have AMD and Microsoft with us this is
really collaborative efforts with us and
now Congress
so
um when we think about a device called
ourselves I myself I'm a gamer so I have
games and steam I have games and epic
games and different lighter rooms so the
first thing comes to all minors if we
want to build a gaming handheld it has
to be a product that that just work in
all the games that I put in the last
five to ten years and I don't want them
to be able to I don't want to be
spending additional money to acquire
games from different platforms limited
to do it I want to make sure that it has
a full compatibility with all the all
the gaming libraries now in the market
today
um
Microsoft is very generous
I'm offering three months of Xbox game
passport free for every RG Ally units to
the consumers hangers
and um we also started to work more
closely with the game Publishers this is
an example that we
Legends by the way my population dropped
today today yeah the jobs today so you
know at the end of this deck you will
get QR codes for everyone here you can
scan if you are going you will get the
free games to be able to play on the
lglr
so um for Our advice we really focus on
poking experiences the first one is
about intuitive control and then the
immersive visuals and audios and then
the performance of posts and our
inclusive software that we kind of feel
to help Gamers to preach that experience
from Windows to uh to the game Library
so first let me talk about the control
um this is actually one of the the
biggest challenge that we had so when we
build these products we basically think
about how we build a product outside
need usually you know we have
experiences in laptop and desktops we
actually build a product inside out it
depends on the components that you use
for the products that you kind of design
the chassis and encroaches to fit it
with this we wanted to be outside so
it's a product that fits in your hands
it should be intuitive it should be
natural when you're holding it you know
it's it's just natural so um ways to the
design canvas of samples in the last
five years and these are all the workout
designs that we have initially trial all
the different form factors and finally
when we when we come down to this form
factor that you see on audio Airline you
knew that this is the right effective
for yourself
so um it's all about your hands right so
in your hands out a few things that's
really
um that's really intuitive to you one is
your thumb so your thumb is your most
commending finger on on your on your
gaming console right so your thumbs
should be able to reach out to the
thumbstick should be able to reach out
to all the buttons so uh when we design
the Roja light we actually take the um
the tested and isometrical layouts by
Xbox game controllers so it will be
similar So within your thumb you should
be able to reach everywhere and then
it's your grip with the finger at the
back so the finger at the back where
actually that that you wrap around the
device and you should allow you to have
access to them
so you can have customized settings with
your local keys that are back and that
is your problem your problem is how you
hold the device
here
um actually wrapping around the edge of
the controller and this allows you to
have a comfort wraparounds that meld
into your hands so we actually have a
three two degree angle on the uh on the
size and 40 degree angle on the layout
so you kind of just feel like you're
you're playing the device and how you
want to hold it naturally
this
how do you communist equality so every
devices that we built we actually have
to go through a very very tough test and
you went through 10 millions of button
faces and two millions of the joysticks
and then we're going to talk about
weight so when we know that we have to
put a very incredible performance into
this device we actually have to think
through how we actually
manage our weight distribution of the
device so we started with the heatsink
we have at the open system but in order
to get the weight reduced we actually
thinner the thermal feed is from 0.15
millimeter it creates 0.1 millimeters
and then next we have to think about the
airflows internally so we kind of held
out some of these areas on the chassis
it's not only reduces the weight it also
allows better influence and then finally
to Improvement rigidity we have to use
aluminum frames for both the battery
bracket as well as the the panel bracket
with all this you still end up to do 608
grams which now as the light is gaming
handheld device in the market and um at
this size so
so we're pretty proud
you're pretty fast
okay so um I want to talk about music
videos and Sons uh we know that in order
to give you the optimized gaming
experience we need to get the spirit
rights for the next
so we're actually offer a seven inch
full HD display
um one thing about this is really think
about Gamers thinking this I'm gonna go
with them so you know um listen not real
that we've been thinking is you can be
by the beach you know by the swimming
pool and still have the device outdoor
so we have the buttons up to 500 volts
we also use it Omega relock glass for
the protein this will actually reduce
the specular reflections of the device
um so when you are Outdoors you know you
will still see the lights penetrate
through from the phone screen itself
we also thought about the immersive
audio experience so we have uh one watt
speakers on both sides so in total two
Watts but it's front facing from firing
to you so um with the smart amp and WMS
once you try it out you'll feel like
that that sound experience is really
different
and then we want to talk about graphic
performance
so um we worked closely in covered with
energy to feel a risen C1 series
processor and I won't steal the
thumbnail that anything to talk more to
tell you more about this this spatial
Apu but it does have the radius
architecture it also have the neon
Networks
um when we think about the device with
the performance that
offered to a customer we actually think
about the same not real result of how we
actually use the device so internally
when we build this we think about three
different scenarios one we call them
knee high the other one we call it we
time and then the last one was Prototype
so let me talk about me time for a while
meantime is when you have the device and
you're playing
with solo right you play games like this
training your edit stories you get into
the Epic stories of the games like
Spider-Man and all
um you can play this on the go on the
flight to be honest although I feel give
me laptops and I never came out
nevertheless but with this as we can uh
in the air on the flight so this is
actually a device that allows you to do
that so that's what we call behind
second is what we call we kind and um I
think a better word is party time so if
you are at home connect this to a DMR
adapter and grab a couple of the
controllers with
um and then we have a body right you can
play NBA 2K p523
um you can play thumbs up party games
that actually you know Blends the family
together
yes
[Music]
the program is when you're connected to
XG mobile from XG mobile is external
Graphics that we've been building for
the last three years it will offer you
the latest graphic performance and when
you connect to xtremo I also have all
the connectors IO so you can connect the
keyboard and mouse so what it actually
does it elevates your gaming experience
from Full HD to 4K even with retracing
right and at the same time because it
has connectivity with the keyboard mouse
you know if you're playing Esports typos
this really turns you you're into this
voice support
and with all the benefits of the
hardware the hardware advantages that we
are able to offer to you you get the
latest pcie for the latest lptdr5 memory
and also the high-speed use UHS 2 micro
SD card as a storage extension
uh Wi-Fi 6E is crucial
um this is the experience that you know
if you want to go cloud gaming Wi-Fi 6E
or Netflix right Wi-Fi 60 is crucial
because you can really enjoy that and
cloud gaming actually allows you to
instant extends to a lot of the contents
and without Wi-Fi 60 that the experience
will just be heavily distances
I'm going to talk about our Cooling
so on the cooling side of things
it's something that we have to figure
out in a different orientation so
different to a laptop or desktop that we
built desktop stays on the desk and
laptop you know sit on the system of
your lap or sit on the desk as well with
this you will be everywhere all right
you will be on the train you'll be lying
down on the bed you'll be on the couch
so we need to make sure the cooling and
the panes are stable enough in different
type of orientations
so we created what we call a zero
gravity pipe zero gravity heat pipe
actually use the Capri force that
literally
have the the liquids stay on the edge of
the heat pipes so even though we are in
different orientations it's not moving
around so you would deliver that
consistent
um cooling for for your device
and we use a blueberry
um band that will reduce the turbulence
as well as reduce the noise
okay we want to talk about the software
um I'm going to create is a software
that you're familiar with we currently
have them and now a lot and now a lot of
time in desktop but when we think about
the handheld device we need to go to the
next layer one thing is being able to
collect all your libraries in one
central place so whether your games are
in steam or epic this will allow you to
scan all the different games that you
have downloaded to the device and put
them into one Central Library phone so
you can pretty much launch all your
games that you download the thumb once
into a location
the other thing is
um you have three ways to interact with
the advisor you have the joystick
movement doing direct with the device
like a controller you also have to
figure out how we have the keyboard
announcements as well as the touch
screen so it does all three at the same
so we want to deliver all those come
true to you so we offer you a customized
software that you can actually go in and
map the keys whether to a keyboard to a
mouse to a controller
um that would that customization
ability is is offered to you
um we can also customize your text zones
on your on your thumbstick and you can
also customize your hair Triggers on
your clear figures you can also
customized hair triggers at this volume
here
let's go
so we the screen we are thinking
but we are talking about RS
honestly
yes
so aurasync is a RGB lighting that we
work with the game Publishers that
delivers the immersive unlocking facts
to
to use of when you when you are running
out you can see the overall lights will
actually apply the facts of the game and
doing the extension to the green lights
around the joystick
wheels are built in one tap command
center right here you can actually
customize all the shortcuts here so uh
when you're in the games and you want to
choose some certain settings right away
you don't have to jump
through all those savings obviously you
have settings of the game in the as a
Content but you also have power settings
with command center right here to change
the same profile performance profile the
controller profile as well as some of
the uh you can you can use the real-time
monitor to look at your FPS and look at
your processor temperature as well
and you never have to miss a moment
because we will have the media libraries
here so when you recrow your game on the
screenshot of your game you know you
will be one Central application for you
also we understand that with this device
without a keyboard it's going to be hard
for you to login so with your five
metric fingerprint scanners so when you
tip
so pretty much that's it oh jli is our
first step to really bring PC gaming to
a handheld device